zusammen haben sie auch den eindruck
dass dieser ganze weihnachtscircus immer
aufwendiger wird das geht an bei der
weihnachtsdeko du musst das ganze haus
leuchten und blinken dass man sogar auf
dem mond noch sagt scholz da unten bitte
das wird nix mehr
und erst beim plätzchenbacken aber gut
da kann ich sie beruhigen
er brauche seinen grund im anhänger weil
mehr plätzchen sorte renate aus amberg
können sie nicht button 681 verschiedene
sorten hat sie heuer gebacken und damit
wird es jetzt jeden moment ins guinness
buch der rekorde aufgenommen um ein
außenreporter karl kralinger ist bei ihr
und darf alle 681 sorten probieren 681
sorten war noch zehn sorten später dass
es nach 15 sorten war restlos fertig
aber paul kralinger er ist natürlich ein
anderes kaliber ist alles in butter
alles im zucker beziehungsweise alles im
ofen weil brüssel nämlich gerade die 681
sorte von der renate und somit auch die
letzte und die werde ich
selbstverständlich auch noch in meinen
plätzchen bewertungsbogen eintragen sehr
gut sehr gut weil nur die ersten 200 die
restlichen 480 sie waren irgendwie nicht
mehr so gut ist das ist die renate
groenewold
es ist der vom guinness buch das ist
daher grünwald es ist der vom fernsehen
und ihr könnt euch jetzt gerne
unterhalten
ich brauchte in der pause ja wahnsinn
renate wie kriegt man so viele
unterschiedliche plätzchen sorten zu
haben das schon beeindruckend aus
jamaika also hier zum beispiel das dach
das ist jetzt ein schwarzweiß gebäck und
das ist ein weiß schwarz naja besser
das sind spitzbogen und esther das sind
spitz mädchen und das da ist ein spitze
trieb ihn zum test das sind spitzenküche
balinger sorgt wie einst mini plätzchen
des opfers doch noch
die 691 die sorte mich am arsch das ist
geplatzt
diese ganze platz erzählt gerade jetzt
ziehen sie sich nicht rein damit und
mahlzeit
[Musik]
ich hab ja okay ich gebe es weiter ist
das jetzt der vom guinness-buch renate
ihr habt eine gute nachrichten für sie
anscheinend dass gerade ihr rekord
gebrochen worden
seine bilder aus know how der mine
soeben 725 sorten plätzchen gemeldet das
gibt's doch nicht
ich stehe seit elf monaten in der küche
ich lass mir davon seiner blöden
erinnern ich meine gott kaputt machen
ich packe zusätzlich sofort wieder hin
und vorerst weiter
[Musik]
und das auch nur so in report der shop
ist kein zuckerschlecken main aus
reporter karl öllinger